lors de la séance des questions au
gouvernement le premier ministre lui
même n'a pas exclu de faire adopter la
réforme des retraites
grâce aux 49 3 lorsqu'il faut prendre
ses responsabilités je le fais sans
hésiter et j'utilise tout la
constitution rien que la constitution
mais bien toute la constitution
des dizaines de milliers d'amendements
déposés un seul article adopté
la majorité veut se sortir de la
stratégie d'obstruction de l'opposition
il faut que cette loi retraite aboutisse
moi je suis persuadé que c'est une bonne
chose pour la nation française
à un moment ou un autre il faut qu'on y
arrive en tout cas notre souhait à nous
c'est que les débats se tiennent dans
l'hémicycle mais pour le socialiste
serge letchimy le gouvernement prendrait
un très gros risque politique en ayant
recours aux 49 3 ces deux gouvernements
utilisent le 49-3 ce déni de démocratie
je dirais même scandale démocratique tu
es là c'est savamment de contresens de
l'histoire
je pense que les comptes des
conséquences pour la majorité serait
très grave au niveau municipal david
lorion pour les républicains propose lui
de reporter l'examen du texte pour
retrouver davantage de sérénité
repoussons les tubes à la fin de la
conférence de financement de manière à
ce qu'on ait les vrais chiffres
on est quelques précisions évidemment
sur ce texte
et puis on aura évidemment plus de temps
pour élaborer un texte nouveau qui est
un texte fondamental pour des millions
de retraités en france 49 3 ou pas les
mesures relatives aux retraités ultramar
ans seront décidées par ordonnances et
les parlementaires n'auront pas leur mot
à dire
l'outre-mer est l'angle mort de la
réforme des retraites il n'y a eu aucun
débat c'est une habitude on traite
l'outre-mer comme une espèce de
l'adjuvant
à côté quoi le gouvernement pourrait
décider d'enclencher larmes du 49-3 lors
d'un prochain conseil des ministres